COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I show how to extend
tracing to every aspect
of your cloud-native
application.
Will our performance
stay inside the lines?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of my favorite things
about managed services like App
Engine is that your requests
are automatically traced,
letting you look
at a given request
and see where various
execution time is
going without you having
to write any code yourself.
Sadly, if you
wanted the same sort
of data for your
non-managed services,
it meant a lot of custom
code, custom deployments,
and a whole new team to write
a custom dashboard UI for you.
But not any more.
Stackdriver has recently
released a library
which allows your
non-managed code
to get the same tracing
awesomeness with less
hassle to you.
Using the newly created
OpenCensus library,
you can get instrumentation
data from any VMs or containers
running in your application
across a number of languages
including Java, Python,
Node.js, Golang and more.
Heck, you could even run it on
your non-Google cloud services
and get that data, too.
The client-side library works
by patching well-known modules
in your application in order
to label and measure latency
of RPCs and incoming requests.
And for the not so
well-known functions,
you can also add custom
spans to your code
that catch the important
bits that fall between.
All that data is then
collected and displayed
in a nice, consistent
UI in the Cloud Console
to help you track down where
your performance is going.
If you're interested in getting
started with Stackdriver
Tracing, check out the article
linked in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great "Cloud
Performance Atlas" content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]